summer time i mean his his followers are
like you got to go back and do something
right
every time he comes out we get more
shahadas every time he comes out we get
more viewers every time he comes out
we get more subscribers every time he
comes out we get
more people at that event that come and
become muslim
but that's the problem his intention is
not to seek the truth right and if it
was he'd be muslim by now
but when your intent is just to make
content
and just to get money then that's not
that's not the
intention that hidayah comes with but
allah and god we will we hope allah
guides him
and you know our that will continues
[Music]
[Music]
doubts honestly aren't always bad
because if you're doubting something
like logically speaking or even if it's
like something that has to do with
morality
once you find the answer to that it
boosts your iman even more
because you you don't just get this
feeling of okay
i'm neutral again you get this feeling
of i can't even believe i doubted that
bro
and then you become even closer to islam
let's get into this q a bismillah all
right question number one
i am a fantasy fiction writer as for my
research i found that fiction is hell
as long as i bring moral values to the
table my question is can i write about
superheroes
as they have supernatural powers like
superman for example
i'm going to give a generic answer but
there are there are some specifics that
i'm not going to be able to get into
today
um generically writing fictional stories
is permissible
because it's not as long as you don't
try to attribute it to reality
right um even things that you know
may not be of use like you know the
arabian nights and things like this
but when you get into things where you
start to attribute things to a superhero
that would be only
allowed for allah and so on um then
those would not be permissible so i
would say if you do want to go into that
field
get a good scholar that you can ask
specific questions about okay i'm going
to write about this
in this way is it okay all right
is one committing shirk or kuffar when
they
watch anime or movies that contain
elements of shirk and kofir
no i i mean watching something does not
make you cafe
but i would not suggest that you watch
things that would that could
corrupt you is it permissible to use
products that contain glycerin
uh what what's the issue with glycerol
well concerns derive from like
animals like pigs so there
you would you would have to first find
out what animal is it derived from right
if it's from
fish glycerin if it's uh
bovine which is beef and so on then the
rulings are going to
differ if it's big glycerin and the
product is going to be on you during
salad and there's majasa
so i mean if you can avoid it avoid it
if you cannot then check the source
speaking of salah that's the next
question does one who miss one single
prayer exit the fold of islam
no are all his good deeds null and avoid
now missing salah
does not make you kafer tarq of salah
makes you careful
missing salah like for example uh it was
time for assad and you were driving and
you were like a cancel over because i'm
on the freeway blah blah blah
and you should not it's a sin but you
missed it from its time and prayed it in
the time of maghrib
sinful but not a catholic if somebody
says
i don't want to pray salah anymore
whether it's out of laziness or not
then the issue would be that that does
it reach to the level of talk of salah
meaning
that have they just you know went
through a phase or
they totally abandoned salah under the
sharia the khalifa would then give him
three days of sitting and saying hey you
gotta start your salah again
and if they insisted that they don't
then
that's more than just being lazy but
anyway so if somebody completely
abandoned salah
tarkov salah this is kufr but if
somebody prays sometimes and misses
sometimes and
doesn't pray sometimes i mean not that i
suggest you do that because
it's definitely a major sin but we don't
consider that kaffir
salaf said whoever abandons allah
says you get extra thick prayer mats for
comfort
but the forehead isn't properly touching
the ground due to the amount of material
in between the forward and the ground
does this nullify
sagitta it does not because
you are still pretty much even though
there's a barrier between you and the
earth but you're still putting your head
on the ground meaning
that even if you're like on a wood
platform
you're still touching your head down
right it doesn't mean it has to be on
dirt right
but if i mean if some people put like a
pillow
and then your hands are touching and
then the pillow keeps you up that would
that would invalidate to someone
okay well there's a lot of
ridiculous comments that's what i'm
skipping some of them
i do have one in the meantime on sp
specifically on anime would it be
haram or makru or something to watch
anime because it's
like portrayal of living beings
so to draw living beings is haram
to watch it i mean not necessarily
but again anime has other issues i mean
first and foremost
uh the appropriateness of some of them i
mean
some of them are rape and massacre and
stuff based
so obviously that's not permissible for
a muslim to watch um some of them have
very silky concepts that
might corrupt especially little
children's data and things you
definitely don't want to do that
um but at the same time you also don't
want to go overboard like somebody
watches
miyasaki spirit away and you're like
you're kafir for watching it like nah
okay take it easy bro
uh there are rules and regulations from
and so on so
all right so it says
nah i found one but i'm not gonna answer
it's like too simple brother just google
it
yeah it was uh man i lost it
[Laughter]
it was okay there you go nah come on
that's that's the rhetorical question
is this a contradiction in the quran one
says allah can have a son
and the other one says he cannot so
chapter 39 verse 4 says had been allah's
will to have offspring he could have
chosen
whatever he willed of his creation now
this is so easy and then
uh surah anam verse 101 he is the
originator of the heavens and earth how
could he have children when he has no
mate
of course so i mean this is very simple
but i'll say it anyway
which is that allah can do whatever he
wants we do not
put restrictions on allah
allah is able to do anything but allah
subhanahu wa
he tells us about some of the
restrictions that he has put on himself
out of his honor and dignity
and one of them is that allah has chosen
not to have spouses or children because
it is not befitting the greatness of
allah
right this is that question people ask
is you know can
allah make a rock that he can't lift
this is it's oxymoron right
it's like saying can there be a square
circle right um
the the point here is that allah's
greatness
is there and from the greatness of allah
is that he is not in need
and a person with children and spouses
these are things that are people in need
so we say allah can do anything he wants
we stop there we don't go into what
about this what about that we just leave
it that that's what allah told us
but we say allah has chosen not to
yeah can i have a point guys this is by
the way though
this is my i don't know if you can see
it man i can't see it uh my
inbox has 14 026
messages so your audience is getting
this special
time to give those answers masha'allah
i love this so when it comes to the eyes
i don't know the arabic and i don't know
if you know specifically does it mention
a son as in a begotten son like like
no this is this is uh which is allah
this is a type and
we understand explaining something
it's not saying he does or doesn't but
it is saying that if allah will did sure
he could right allah can do anything
that is something that we cannot say
that allah
can't right but allah subhanallah has
sent certain rules on himself
one of them is that he has no children
no wife no father no beginning no end
allah does not deceive people allah does
not
lie that is that is the rules that allah
set on himself
i mean from his honor many ayats and
they don't want to go deep into the
their style is called to explain
something to you
yeah yeah so lam yelled
um is also from allah um
deciding that it's like it's not be
fitting for him and choosing of course
but what we know about allah is what he
revealed about himself
right if allah
[Music]
come on like the the artist of allah is
greater than the seven samaat and all
that put together
how are you going to even try to
comprehend this yeah we believe in the
quran
as it is revealed with the mind that
allah revealed it with at the time we
don't go into all these
weirdness next question come on my
question
why does for number seven show up a lot
in islam we circle seven times around
the kaaba
there's there are what grammar bro there
are seven verses
let me just explain look um
people that go into these numeric things
either have too much time on their hands
or and they have some other kind of
issue because look if i went to three i
can find plenty of things with three
winter and
three uh any uh this or that i mean
uh and uh you do it three times
i could find all this stuff right if
you're going to 40 like you can find a
lot of
references for 40 and you know 40 this
and 40 that if i went to 30 30 jews and
30
this and you know how many number of
angels what's the point
look if it was something that you needed
to know about
for your allah will tell it to you
and if not don't worry about it
and life is simple like you've got to
complicate this all right
the question i have for the is how do we
make up
if we forget them during the prayer for
example zohara's four
say i pray two and when i get up and i'm
not sure if i'm on my fourth or
third what do i do in this situation we
just had a fair
dash on this uh i don't know if you can
post it yet on the
bottom channel first thing i would say
is
go to the mazdabab channel there is ah
follow one of the gurus all the way
through so you can understand because
there is
ahu and making up and all of that which
i can't do here due to time
but in essence if you're not sure about
three or four you go with
you go with the lower number is so then
because that is yatin and your pain now
you're gonna be shocked and the opinion
is not done away
with doubt so if you
if your doubt is between three and four
it's three
then you will add another rakah and you
will make sujud sahur at the end of it
before the slim after the slim watch the
video inshallah
all right we got a question from our
personal brother you know not biological
though
brother fletcher uh the question is
sheikh uthman advice to american
talib that are looking to learn and
master
arabic while they are living and what do
you think of muslims that are interested
in doing street dawah doing the same
format
of using and putting sticky notes in a
bible show the corruption of it
without studying or reading it all like
you did
those are really good questions
mashallah um so
first and foremost may allah make us all
sincere to love
i think every muslim has certain
knowledge that is obligatory on them
how to make wudu correctly how to make
salah correctly how to
make hajj correctly correctly not just
my dad did it that way
right and if you don't have that
knowledge
stop watching videos stop doing
everything else and seek that knowledge
first
right don't sit there waste your time
with
refutations and all of that if you don't
have that base knowledge right
so uh that is for the line on every
muslim
if you're able to get to a shaykh and
and you
are
rarer less less common than
uh i don't know i mean finding uh uh
ten thousand dollars laying around in
the street or something nowadays
unfortunately you know
because people are not developing
themselves in knowledge right
um but if you can find a shaykh and
alhamdulillah this is the thing on the
quran or sunnah on a good afrida where
the salaf
take that sheikh and study if you're
unable to
try to travel i mean the past traveled
right go
go to muslim countries go to persia's go
to there's knowledge
apply at different universities if you
don't get into universities don't give
up
and he go like i did save your money go
rent a place go sit with the shirt sit
in his house and that masjid
sit as a feet and learn that knowledge
that you need
um right if you're unable to you know
try to find somebody online try to
get a hold of sheikh you know um if
you're unable to do that even
alhamdulillah blesses with youtube and
all these videos nowadays
find series uh that are online we have
arabic language series we have all those
free of charge
watch those there are other mashallah uh
and then there are actual that have
videos in english online that you can
benefit
but don't go to like just like videos
but go to like an actual book like a
series you know like
like we have zadon mustafi it's an
actual third book so go through each one
you know we have lumate
right like try to follow one of those
through inshaallah
and gain that knowledge um regarding
using the bible uh
not everybody has to read the whole
bible to give that one things uh
but you should know it well enough that
um any if they come back at you you will
be able to respond like you don't want
to go in like
half caught right um you know you want
to be sure of what you're saying so
if you watch the one message foundation
channels videos
um we go at it with with preachers and
priests and
apologists and morons and intelligent
people and all of that right
so you will see those back and forths so
when i do mention the contradictions the
stuff they come back with and how i
respond and so on
so if you can get all of that then i
think you're good to go but if you just
pick up a bible and mark it up
and then they hit you with something
back and you're like oh
you know so i would say you know get get
at least get the training from the
videos inshallah before you start doing
it
alhamdulillah all right fletcher hope
that's enough for that question
next question is from a sister question
explain the concept of right-hand
possession
is it applicable today if there is a war
and why not just simply get married
tell you the right hand possessions has
nothing to do with
marriage i mean somebody wants to get
married get married i mean alhamdulillah
right
but the issue here gets to be what do
you do in case scenarios of war
right so in war you have a right-hand
possessions are only through war i mean
that's the only way
it gets there right so in war especially
in the time of rasulullah
and before that and after that what was
the solution
was genocide right people i mean i'm
talking about anonymous so what they
would do is they would take over
area and then when they won they would
just go and massacre everybody and kill
everybody and you know
uh take over the land and the resources
right and we have many examples of this
you can see in history
but allah chose something better he
wanted hidayah for the people
so you can't execute
prisoners in islam unless they have
committed war crimes unless they have
done something
that they could be any uh put to trial
for and so on
um so otherwise you can't just generally
kill prisoners right
so now that you have this situation that
you have people fighting
not just you know you're just walking
around see some dude and grab them nah
you know some people are actually
fighting you they're trying to kill you
right now you win what do you do so in
islam instead of killing them
um you take them in as captives of war
which is a form of slavery there right
in islam we don't have slavery in the
western sense of slavery we've never had
it right
what is the western sense of slavery is
europeans went to africa for example
and based on your race really it wasn't
like they were getting slaves from
northern virginia or something right
they
they took africans as slaves against
their will some of them were princes
some of them were
teachers some of them were just regular
people walking around they kidnapped
them
forced them onto ships they were not at
war there was not a
they're not war prisoners they brought
them to america
the triangle trade tobacco and all that
right you know
and then they took away their identity
they took away their religion it's for
their names they raped them
mastered them uh bred them i mean all
kinds of insane things that
i mean i don't know if it's ever been
done in history that in that way and
it was race-based right i mean it was a
slave trade
mostly of black people from africa even
though there were some others
but this was the main essence of it
islam has never had that alhamdulillah
even though this was done
by people who were christian right what
we do have in islam is if you are taken
as captive or you're taken in as a
captive now you don't have the ability
to just walk out right
but even in that case we don't force a
religion on you we don't take away your
identity
but in this case we will keep you and
and
and make sure that you then find a way
that you can be freed
in a way that benefits umma as well like
if you can teach some people how to read
you can be freed
i mean you can buy your freedom you can
say look you know i'm gonna give you
this much and
i'm going to take my freedom you can
become a muslim
and and the person could free you like
the mawlana fama and
the mawla fatman and become their
students and become
great scholars and so on in that
situation
when you have a woman for example and
she's actively fighting and you take
them as vanima
and she's in your household we know that
that there are there's liable that
things can go and in islam
we don't believe in um any under the rug
kind of stuff like everything should be
evident if you do want to get a wife it
should be clear
if you want to get a second wife and
that's an issue that you can discuss
with your first wife and
go for it but don't go and get a
mistress you know don't go and
visit a prostitute like we don't do that
hypocrisy stuff right
in the same way if you have people that
are now captured slave that are in your
household
a lot this is your right-hand position
but that doesn't have anything to do
with marriage i mean
if you go get married then you get
married like you're not going to wait
for a war to break out and all this kind
of stuff right
is it applicable in our time well i
don't know i mean if you're in a place
of war i guess but
i mean uh this is not something that we
really run into right
like gender identity issues and wars
like that
gender identity issues yeah like battles
with their own gender
fluidity i'm confused what
like that's a controlled battle that's a
real that's a real battle people claim
to have today
uh like they're not sure what their
gender is
oh i got the solution this is easy man
i'm glad you asked this one right
go to the bathroom
and just check
marshall problem solved
should one seek knowledge first then
pursue a secular degree
or vice versa so again that's a question
that like what do you mean by knowledge
if you mean that which is obligatory
then obviously
that has to be taken precedence over
everything like how to make salah
correctly
how to make correctly this is part of
this
knowledge every muslim must have right
so that would be that would be before
anything right
um but if you mean like hadith and uh
and the depth of knowledge then it
depends if you're in a situation where
you can seek that knowledge first and
then do your secular studies
to earn a living go for it if you're not
you can
get a degree save some money and then go
study that's all going to depend on your
situation but the obligatory knowledge
should be given precedence over
everything
question for mon how does he plan for
okay i think how does it plan his time
that's what they're trying to say
and and can you provide any hadith from
the prophet saws life
on organization and daily planning more
specifically
how to build and foster discipline
that's a beautiful question
that i definitely don't have time to
answer in depth but i will give a short
answer
how do i plan my life not very well
apparently because i don't sleep enough
and
so on right but you know i mean i have
work to do
like i'm at work so i mean i gotta go
earn a living you go out you're in your
living
um you go home you you have uh obviously
obligations that you have to do with the
kids
but at the same time i mean every week i
have a series of
rules so those are set um i have
you know fun conversations like this
which you know we trying to plan it out
and one of our brothers and allah warned
him yes he
does my scheduling if it wasn't for him
i'd double book everything
um and you know so you know you try your
best but
a lot of times it's difficult i mean
it's not easy because you're trying to
do a lot of things
and then you have and your own sometimes
your body doesn't keep up you know you
just kind of crash
out you're tired and so on but this is
this is life this life is meant for you
to push yourself you know this
life is meant for you to work hard and
and build your
right regarding rasulallah
of course he had a pattern that he would
follow
and in his praying tahajud and his soul
and how he gave time to the community
and gave time to his family
uh and this is very important for us to
study but i can't give it like in these
few minutes i would suggest you get a
book like shamala shaman
or shimada shetty for cot or any one of
these books about the life of
and his daily actions and look at that
and inshaallah will give you
more insight and if you are unable then
we do have a seerah that is going on on
the mazdabad channel
you can follow those and we'll talk
about the life and how it also makes you
divide up the time and so on
from authentica
all right this is a rather long one but
i'll paraphrase from brother ahmed
assalam please please please ask him how
he managed to continue studying while
taking care of his family in the context
of traveling abroad
to study under scholars did he have
options besides studying in pakistan
how did he start learning quranic arabic
in his early 20s how did he pro okay
that's a lot of questions
how did you progress through quranic
grammar how did he find the right
teachers
so just your whole journey essentially
how expensive can that endeavor become
how much time do you guys ask uh there's
a video i think with on sajid's channel
which kind of talks about a lot of these
things
so uh you can watch that and um
it'll give you more about my life i
think there's been a few that are about
my life that are out there but
i'll give a short answer um when you
make a goal for something then you
find a way you know i mean that like
like when you really want to do
something you will find if you want to
make excuses you make
you can make a billion excuses i could
have made excuses i applied at the
islamic university didn't get in
because i was getting married and at the
time you had to be unmarried and all
this stuff
i could have been like okay that's it
i'm out you know i didn't get in i'm
done but
but i was like no i mean this is
something i need i need knowledge i love
it i want to do it
so i made a niyah i asked allah and
allah
i mean she traveled with me and i i
saved
instead of buying you know fancy cars or
things when i was an engineer i saved
that money and
um you know i took it with me and
traveled a lot with my mother for
any being patient or any um
you know it wasn't easy but you know i
made a goal that's what i want to do
um i mean it's not easy to find a shaykh
i mean i think it's very very very
difficult but
if you try ask allah allah make a way
for you you know
subhanallah i mean i got a hold of
sheikh and he was here in the us
and um and he wrote me at esky and then
i went to a marathon
run to another he wrote me a test i went
[ __ ] and
i tried to find ways and i went to
jordan i went to the place to study
um one of my shield recommended for me
to go to pakistan
and study arabic you know it's kind of a
weird thing but some of the shioks are
really really good in arabic grammar and
uh like eloquence and so on so
i wanted to go there but when i was in
amarat i was studying with the chef in
his house
great opportunity didn't take any money
from me wonderful person
even though i have continuously offered
but i didn't get to practice a lot
because you know in amaranth you could
get away with english urdu and pashto
and i spoke all the other languages
so i went to jordan for one that reason
to just be where i had to speak arabic
and i made a rule for myself
not to speak a mia i took a qasam i'm
not going to speak accent to there
because i wanted to learn arabic for the
quran
not to order at a coffee shop right
so i would be in the street speaking
fusa with like everybody you know like
you know read when it happened like
people would make fun of it people would
be like what are your professors
not class but i didn't care because for
me i had a goal
so i kept to that role and that helped
me practice because in jordan i was
taking buses i was going places
i had to go shopping i mean i couldn't
speak any other language so
i have to do it in arabic and i had to
do in fusing the store owners would
laugh at me like i'm
shopping for you know apples and fosa
and stuff but
who cares right and alhamdulillah that
helped me a lot getting my practice
going when i went to pakistan
the mahat that i was at had a rule only
arabic no
no urdu no nothing else inside so we had
to speak it and
that was all and i studied al-fibrinolic
and you know what that is that is like
an amazing amazing book in
south and so on so uh the shaykh we
should never
make us memorize viewed from you know
from the abhiyat and then
uh come back and read them and then
explain them and it was difficult and
i got laughed at alhamdulillah did it
you know continued the gurus with him
then with hadith and
a lot of benefit that i got there from
them a depth that i didn't find even in
other countries alhamdulillah
but i mean that was an avenue it was
easy for me because i was originally
from pakistan
i mean i had family there and i could do
that but you can do that other countries
are everywhere alhamdulillah i mean not
so much in the west but
in other countries i mean if you have
the ability to go to a certain country
yeah and you ask allah and find the
quran
you will find them inshallah all right
guys make some dua for our shaykh
and his family that allah gives them
barakah blessed them guides them and
protects them i mean
next question is from a sister uh give
the wisdom behind why birthdays are
haram
and you know maybe from there to
christmas and all that
excellent i yet
celebrations are a part of the religious
rulings right meaning
those that those that occur
yearly or a certain pattern right one is
that you just want to throw a party and
nothing wrong with that like this is
mubarak like let's say
uh i come to your city and you're like
hey let's get some steaks throw them on
the barbecue let's do it like you guys
come to san diego we're like hey
let's get some burgers invite some
brothers cool no problem with that
but when you make a reoccurring
festival then there are some rules and
regulations
right um rasul he
went to madinah and they had their own
celebrations not necessarily even
religious celebrations but they had
their own celebration the prophet said
allah has replaced these for you
with that which is better right so he
told us that you can't celebrate those
anymore
now allah has given you these days to
celebrate right
which tells you it's not just an
individual like okay we just want to
make up something
like that right so that's the first
thing to understand
secondly when we talk about celebrations
we have to look at bridges
like where did this come from and as
much as
some people with doctorates from certain
universities may want to avoid this
question nowadays by blinding themselves
even they know better
but the reality is birthdays have a
beginning
in [ __ ] that's where it came from i have
a book called the unusual
uh beginnings of usual or common or
uncommon beginnings of common things
it's national geographic book and you
know if i was home i'd show it to you
guys but
it talks about where things came from
and non-muslims
not like some you know bias here and
they talk about birthdays
started out as a i mean a greek
shitty uh festival to
honor the moon goddess and that's where
the idea of the cake came from and this
is non-muslims undocumented it's right
the round cake like we don't think about
this right
it was supposed to be like the moon
goddess and that's why they would light
candles to illuminate the
moon looking cake to worship the moon
goddess
and they would blow out the andals
making a wish it's unfamiliar
right as a prayer to the moon goddess to
grant their wish
that may not be done as a religious
festival today but those aspects are all
there
those origins are there right we still
have birthdays we still have wishes we
still have candles we still have blowing
out
this is a pagan religious festival
so the hikmah in it is we should not
participate in things that were pagan
ritual festivals right let's take that
to christmas
where did christmas come from is it in
the bible
no any historian credible historian that
said jesus was born
on the 25th of december no
biblical scholars give due to looking at
the
trees and farms and people coming they
give the date of around summer and
spring and so on for the birth of jesus
according to them
so where did the 25th of december come
from
it's a pagan festival that was
integrated into christianity and you can
i mean this
documentation all over the world for
this right
to please pagans and get them into being
christian without having to give up
their pagan festivals easter is the same
um
you know the same is true for halloween
this was a pagan
devil worshiping i mean type of a
festival that now
christians celebrate my christian
neighbors celebrate
and you're like hey this is kind of
devilish don't you think yeah
you know so those
imams and doctors that are like oh and
today we don't take it to the
university's festival
well i mean if you think about it
neither is christmas
i mean most americans or canadians and
stuff don't really think about jesus at
christmas either it was gifts
santa claus reindeer eggnog held that on
christmas trees like another thing i
could do with jesus right if i
when i was in school if i asked any any
kid in my middle school
hey what's christmas about i guarantee
you that zero of them would say geez
right gifts you know it's the highest
suicide rate
christmas time because the people that
don't get their gifts or unable to buy
gas go kill themselves like that's how
materialistic it has become right um
santa claus you know i remember seneca
where did santa claus this was a nordic
green where you know he he became red
because of some artists
and then coca-cola really kind of
promoted the red color for marketing
after that right
before that he used to be wearing green
and he used to have eye patch in the
nordic
tradition this is a nordic warrior type
of a thing
and now you got oh sit on my lap like
whoa
let's sit on some dudes bro
i've been around catholics i'm not
messing with that kind of stuff right
so you got you got christmas trees where
did christmas trees come from
right i mean the bible tells you don't
put gold and silver on trees and this
kind of thing and
you got this decorations going up right
all this is pagan stuff right
we got to draw a line look we're muslim
you want to celebrate
alhamdulillah we got fitter we got adha
you really want to just
throw a family thing out or whatever
every jamaica that read of the week
you got all these things why you gotta
make bidah all these people
bowling and this and that and then when
he'd come to like whatever
so this is the thing um inshallah kind
of longer than i expected to do that
and by the way uh anytime you feel like
you gotta go let us know we'll cut it
off and we'll do a part two for this
because it definitely can be in one
video
all right uh another question please
help share your views in regards
in regards to the following hadith
famous historian ibn jaryar tabari said
was born before islam compiler of famous
hadith collection
of whatever name said asma was sister of
ayishi
was 10 years older than aisha in 73 asma
died at age of 100.
even kathy in his book let me just let
me just stop you because because
i've discussed all of these in the video
right so i have a video on the age of
you if you watch it discuss it regarding
many of these
uh narrations uh like about the age of
aisha
these are historic reports these are not
senate so we can't really check the
chains some of these are opinions of
scholars and so on
um but let me just cut to the chase of
what this question is really about right
and if you watch my video i i explain it
in detail
um the age of ayesha we have a report
that is sahih that mentioned six we have
at the engagement not the marriage
and another sahih report dimension seven
right
so these are both fake narrations so
obviously this this is not something
that
is yani uh like
ages um if we look at this issue
do we have an ayah from quran about the
age of
no do we have a hadith from allah
accept them no doubt that she gives her
age but
in such a muslim she also gives a
different age which shows that there was
not a surety
in her own mind right on top of that as
another thought maybe it was in the
middle of the two and so on
explained that there is there is some uh
leeway for
age here because if you look at the fact
that you had a period of time that you
had no calendar
like today if i ask rami how old are you
he's going to be like well i was born in
xyz
year so i'm just years of age or he'll
check his birth certificate
or his passport right we've got none of
that you have no calendar i mean you
don't have the history calendar that
came in the time
right so you have no numbering you only
have like i'm in field you know
the year of the elephant the year of
rain the year of drought like
that's how you have you have no
numbering right so
the age of ayesha i mean to be very
honest with you
knows best maybe she was six or seven at
engagement and 10 or
11 or so on at the time of marriage
maybe if we look at the other
hadith and that that mentioned some of
the historic events that she
narrated that she could not have at that
young age maybe she was older
that's not really a big issue because
what we do know
is she was at eight which was already
engaged right so that was the normal age
to be married at that time
we do know that no mushrik none of the
enemies of possum
lifted an objection to this they didn't
see it as something different from the
normal
cultural practices of that time how old
should you be to get married when
somebody says 18 well where did you get
that number from right
nowadays you say well you got to go to
middle school then you got to go to high
school then you got to graduate then you
got to do this right
well you didn't have any of that at that
time even men would get very
married very young because they didn't
have four-year degrees before they can
talk about getting married right you
were a 14-15 year old man you were out
there you were
working you were hunting or farming you
got married
right you were a girl you were past the
age of childbearing you were having your
head or
whatever your body was physically ready
you got married
that's how the society was it is not
right for somebody today to sit back and
judge the society
too long ago um regarding those
narrations again i mean i don't i mean
i've spent time on it and so on you can
look at
my video for more details on it but in
the end what does it even really matter
right
i mean whatever it was was appropriate i
just want to give a quick plug
uh again this is just my personal
opinions this is not to you know
contradict any any scholars or anything
there's a youtuber by the name of full
metal theist he goes into a
lot of different um philosophical
arguments and refutations so he made a
video called ending the
pedophile argument if you guys can watch
that uh just or set up full metal theist
very good explanation all right next in
the next
question for sure guys sorry islam i'm
gonna have to excuse myself i have to go
pray
bless you all and until next time i mean
question four what are your thoughts on
how much the mother should be
the way i see it it is a cost of
marriage and intimacy
if it is too high it makes haram
attractive but if it is too low women
aren't
being given their right i think you're
the way you saw it was perfect right
um has to do with the orphan
right it has to do with cultural norms
and the sharia
looks at cultural norms
when we look at for example in our time
let's say in a
region of bangladesh and the norms there
and then you look at let's say
switzerland and the norms there you're
going to find two different cultural
norms
if we in shariah say has to be x amount
of money
then it would not be fair either it
would be too low
and or it'll be too high and that's why
the wisdom of sharia is there is no
minimum or maximum for my health
rather it should show that a person is
serious
about marriage like when you come to
marry somebody and you're like
yo i got a dollar right you really don't
want to hurt that guy right
you want to make sure that he's taking
because you know he's not going to take
the very seriously
right two dollars you know like i said
uh
i mean i do nikaf for people all the
time and the metal is like 50 cents you
know our dollar is like okay well
if you want to do that but but this is
the right of the woman to choose right
now on the other hand um if you make the
mahara million dollars
like what does she come with like you
know a house with her or something like
you know
like come on like you know that's
ridiculous right so
i think people need to kind of
understand like look you need to make it
where the person takes the marriage
seriously you do not want to
under uh any appreciate this great
opportunity of marrying this
wonderful person and at the same time
don't make it a barrier to getting
married
um you know and and just a very
important point on that
it is the woman's right not the family's
right
like this is not something your family
should set the girl who's getting
married that's her hook
and it should be given to her not her
dad trying to get rich off of having
dollars right
you're not selling daughters here you
you have to keep that in perspective
right
so making a major that is culturally
appropriate for the time and place that
you're at
to show seriousness and respect to the
woman and at the same time not making it
a barrier
to getting married i think this question
is going to be really good for you
so salaam alaikum i feel like in the
west we've been programmed to blindly
accept whatever gets thrown at us
be it from the government or from people
like teachers so it makes difficult to
be firm
at times it's also difficult to find the
balance and not be aggressive or mocking
when challenging those ideas and being
firm with our deen
question how does one be firm when it
comes to matters of the deen
but not come across as holier than thou
and rude
at the same time that's a good question
um basically look
we as muslims have to stand up for the
truth
with the best and the best mannerisms
like never sacrificed the truth he never
compromised
what's right but he was never rude
or aggressive or demeaning about it
sometimes he was stern
and sometimes we have to be stern and
sometimes
he was very tolerant and sometimes we
have you have to be able to recognize
situation right
so if you are in school and and in a
there's a conversation about lgbtq xyz
whatever
you know you're a muslim you have the
right to your opinion
uh showing respect to the setting that
you're at
not being vulgar not being combative you
know give your opinion
if you feel that you're unable to then
don't say anything just hate it with
your heart right but
but yeah you should be able to right and
if i say as a muslim i don't agree with
riba-based housing nobody should be
offended by that and if they are that's
really their problem right
at the same time i mean if i walk up to
somebody and i'm like you're going to
hell for buying a house under about
that's wrong because that's not the way
of rasulullah
right so danny we give dawah and
sometimes you have to be like look you
know go walk your little dog right you
got to like
be stern about it and sometimes you know
you let them speak and speak and speak
and speak and
they're going off and we're laughing
giving them cookies and whatever right
so you have to kind of
gauge the situation and understand it
some of them will come with experience
and time
but the best thing i can say is you know
look at the life of rasulullah
see how he dealt with different
situations and if you want to see a more
contemporary watch the videos that we
have on dawa when we deal
at different universities answering
questions from
and see how we deal with it inshallah
you can get a good uh
gauge from that inshallah
all right next question i'm a new
homeschooling parent and would like some
advice on that
oh no there's more and would like to
know what also
what islamic books or classic texts to
teach my kids
from an elementary level i've seen other
homeschoolers use questionable sufi
texts
and would like my children to be on the
correct pita and manhattan
i would like to make a blog about this
at some point inshallah
first thing i think it's a very good
idea to homeschool your kids
i homeschooled all my four kids uh one
of them alhamdulillah just graduated
with a 4.0 topped his class number one
test course in his in his state
testing even though he was homeschooled
so homeschooling doesn't mean that you
sacrifice the level of education
secondly it's not going to be easy
so you know try to get with some
homeschooling groups some tutoring
groups try to find some
volunteer tutors maybe some paid tutors
because you yourself might not be able
to teach them especially at later grades
earlier grade disease
right
regarding islamic education i don't know
what i mean do you speak arabic your
children speak arabic like i don't know
what your level is
so what i'm going to suggest if you go
to majduribat channel go to the playlist
there's a playlist for books and
research things called books and
research
and in it i have one series or five
videos about the books that every muslim
household must have
um and then i have series about
developing and [ __ ] different matune
and
different sciences so you can watch
through those and maybe blog about them
if you like
and uh use that as a good guideline to
how to
develop your children in knowledge so on
um any but in every
science that there are beginning mutual
if you get the book hello
it's called the etiquette of seeking
knowledge of sheikh bhuzad
he talks about some books there if you
look at the kitab
or shift i mean or the explanation of
helia taliban by sheikh vinod i mean
which is the explanation of the
etiquette of seeking knowledge etiquette
is available in english uh the
explanation i don't believe it is that
insulin arabic but they talk about
different books you kind of grow like
in example you can begin with like
some beginning text and then go up to
like al mukhney and so on
um inshallah if you watch our videos we
talk about how to develop students in
that inshallah
one more one more let's do two more
because i have one from
youtube and one personal one tomorrow
we're done
perfect my question first is
our skin fades
which is a type of haircut which is
shaved
and left right so you shave a part of
the head and you leave the part of the
head
some of the took it to be makru but
either i mean makru and haram doesn't
mean that it's okay like it maku doesn't
mean okay like some
uh some of our brothers nowadays like
somebody says well that doesn't mean
it's okay that you still shouldn't do it
right
so what is that when you shave a part of
the head and
like you see the marine haircut we call
it like somebody shaves that part of the
head and then they leave it
um this is there is there's mana in
hadith whether you take it
either which way forbidden
that doesn't mean your hair has to be
all the same size like this is
whereas people take a little confusion
there and i know the stomp you is like
you know when people read it
they kind of take it that way but but
let me explain that rasulallah
used to cut his hair at three lengths
like you know which is you know
mid year later lower and shoulder level
right
so if for example uh angel cuts his hair
here
the hair that is from the bottom of the
hair and the hair that is from the top
is not going to be the same
length right so so that doesn't mean all
your hairs are exactly the same length
but you should not shave a part of the
head and leave a part of the head
or seem like it even the
of the things that are haram is
so if you cut your hair let's say a
three here
and a five up on top nothing wrong with
that right
um but if you cut it at a one here and a
seven up top then it looks like the
shaved
side so then you get into a gray area
right where you should not
so if you're talking about shaving and
then leaving then you should not
if it's like like a really close trim
and really long then you're still
imitating that way so you shouldn't but
if your hair is shorter on the sides and
on top in and of
itself that's not a problem all right
question for my sister a question for
the chef is it obligatory for me to work
if my parents want me to
to be honest i want to just seek islamic
knowledge
and be a good housewife and mother and i
know that would upset my mother quite a
bit
what should i do this is something i
hear quite a lot so
really
a yeah of our brothers would be
interested in knowing where sisters like
that are at i know
yeah right so um if you
obeying your parents is obligatory but
not in disobedience of allah
so if your parents are putting you in a
workplace where there are men
there is obviously a danger to you
because you know the metoo movement has
shown us that you know the workplace can
be very dangerous for women and so on
then in that case if there is no
necessity like you don't have to earn
money to eat kind of a thing
then you shouldn't and you should tell
your parents look allah has made it
haram for me to be interacting with men
without necessity and i want to keep my
life within halal and we hope that a
good muslim parent will listen to that
and if they don't then you don't have to
obey them
the disobedience to allah now
if your parents want you to work in a
place which is totally halal and it's
all women and there's no danger
and you have a necessity or something
then yes you should obey your parents
um but even then i mean if you tell your
parents look i want to get married
i want to i need to live a good islamic
life being the cornerstone of
society a good mother a good wife
then nothing wrong with that that's the
way you should do it and if they force
you not to
you don't have to obey them because you
don't obey them
in the discipline to the khalak but i
would really suggest you know to
try to find a good brother and who's
also i mean
don't rush into it who's also any upon
the quran and sunnah and things
and get married and live a good healthy
life
one quick thing i wanted to know i know
you said one more but i went through all
the 414
comments aside from the you know clutter
and hate
comments and random spam and all that
actually just one more real question
that's it all right
go ahead do it for my sister this one
the
question for sheikh uthman is it
acceptable to memorize the quran by
merely listening if you can't read
arabic that well
asking this because prophet muhammad saw
some couldn't read or write but does
that also apply to everyone as well
or is it just better to learn arabic and
touch with the proper way
honestly i'm sort of asking this because
since i was a kid the way i would
memorize is i would watch
english word for word videos when the
surah in arabic in the background with
this one and they're beginning back on
i would do this since my parents
couldn't teach me now that i'm older
it's a bit hard to learn how to read the
quran
when i already know how the words will
sound if that makes any sense
like what is the proper way to res that
my brain on this because it's
really making this process so much more
difficult
look if you can memorize by listening
memorize by listening like different
people memorize different ways some
people memorize by memory by kind of
taking a photographic picture of the
page and that's why they keep the same
software memorization some people
memorize better by listening i
personally memorize better
quran better by listening and reading at
the same time like
i'm reading and listening it helps me
personally but that's a personal
preference there is no sharing outcome
that you have to read or you can't read
or you must listen or don't right so
that's
the only the only the thing i will
advise is
it's very important for you to recite
the quran to a teacher
you will not catch your own mistakes
even rasulullah
so whether you memorize by reading or
listening it's not really the point
but you should try to find a teacher
who you can recite the quran to would
listen to it to catch your mistakes
and that is essential past that reading
listening is up to you
all right guys with that being said if
you made it this far comment down below
hashtag sheikh uthman goes live if the
next time we do talk to the brother you
want us to do a live stream
and angel do you have any question for
the check before we end it off
is the whole david thing real
uh we planned we came to come out on
brian knew it man
there's no way this man keeps coming out
there just to keep getting home
um you know the thing with these guys is
uh originally they came out and they
made this big fuss that they were going
to destroy aragawa and i i didn't even
know they existed like i had heard their
names here and there but whatever right
um and they came out and alhamdulillah
as you guys have all seen the video they
got
i mean subhanallah even non-muslims come
and tell us like these guys got
inaudible right they got destroyed
they couldn't even explain their base
core belief right
and and they you know so they acted
differently one of them
uh hashum decided to just have a
meltdown on in his bathroom on tv
or on videos or whatever and living
rooms and just
you know whatever that's his thing right
the crook got
lost somewhere i don't know i haven't
heard about him but hammer time
i mean his his followers are like you
got to go back and do something right
this guy came a second time video was
online he got destroyed again so he came
a third time and
same thing and every time he comes out
we get more shahadas
every time he comes out we get more
viewers every time he comes out
we get more subscribers every time he
comes out we get
more people at that event that come and
become muslim
and and alhamdulillah we have videos
since they came out look at the videos
of the number of shadows we don't record
all our shahadas but
we have so many videos of people taking
shahada alhamdulillah we have
that mexican brother that came out
recently and said you know he watched
the videos and
alhamdulillah he became muslim because
of it we had a pastor come out with his
son and say look
i watched the videos and i left being a
pastor because of it now i learned about
islam and
a christian was telling us you destroyed
them right so
he came out of fourth time right and and
we're like cool
right and subhanallah we caught them
lying repeatedly and the only way they
can make their stuff is when they go
back and they sit
alone without me there and clip and
doing this and all that stuff
that's the only way when they come face
to face their reality comes out
so allah has made this plan and that
they come and and
increase the tawa and we hope they keep
coming and keep increasing the dawah and
inshallah we're starting up new
locations the new cities that that was
growing
alhamdulillah we have more shahadas than
ever we have more subscribers and
viewers than ever
so uh you know uh even if
you know i almost wish we did pay him i
kind of feel bad dude flies out i think
new york rents hotels there's always a
man he's getting enough money from all
the people
that want to watch him so he's got all
that money and he's still begging on
their channel for more money
bro imagine somebody after life for a
quick buck here
yeah but how crazy would it be if this
man actually
takes a shot at you know a lot of people
have this
uh i i asked him in one of the debates i
told him what's your intention to come
out
right because when i asked him of the
bible he's like i'm not an expert in the
bible
oh you're not like you're not expert in
the quran for sure
and you don't know the bible philosophy
what philosophy i couldn't answer right
so i felt like why do you come out like
what's the point like in the end
basically he's just out there he's like
a boxer like you go you go in the ring
you get beat up
and then you're like well i still need a
check so i'm going to go back in that
ring and i'll get beat up again
but i still need that check right it's
like conor mcgregor kind of strategy
right
and you know we'll be the habibs for him
any time of the week insha'allah no
problem
but that's the problem his intention is
not to seek the truth
right and if it was he'd be muslim by
now but when your intent
is just to make content and just to get
money
then that's not that's not the intention
that hidayah comes with but allah and
god we will we hope allah guides him
and uh you know it's not going to hold
you know
it's not going to benefit us our world
continues you know if somebody becomes
muslim it's good for them
and our dawah alhamdulillah by the will
of allah allah is
going really well i mean we we got
shahadahs we got more videos of shadow
we haven't been posted yet
um you know we got we got you look at
the comments brothers like comment like
ten of my friends became muslim from
watching the david wood debate
you know i became muslim so many people
i became muslim i became muslim
alhamdulillah
so let them come along
all right all right brothers
[Music]
all right bro i'm out
i got one last thing for you bro who is
gay
you are gay am i though
how you know well how about this
if we get 50 people commenting down
below on hell is gay
g-a-e then you're gay bro
i don't think a voice like that i'm a
counter though
nah all right bro with that being said
may allah bless you all thank you for
your time
tune in next time with sheikh uthman ibn
farooq
from omf the lion himself salaam alaikum
doubts honestly aren't always bad
because
if you're doubting something like
logically speaking or even if it's like
something that has to do with morality
once you find the answer to that it
boosts your iman even more
because you you don't just get this
feeling of okay alhamdulillah i'm
neutral again
you get this feeling of i can't even
believe i doubted that bro
and then you become even closer to islam
[Music]
um
[Music]
um